era este el gesto que faltaba por parte
de Colombia para volver a reconocer el
gobierno de Nicolás maduro
definitivamente
Buenas noches gracias por la invitación
efectivamente sí es un paso importante
que esa visita por parte del presidente
Petro haya sido en Miraflores para
Nicolás Maduro prácticamente es un
espaldarazo que ha venido de la mano de
otros presidentes en la región que no se
han atrevido a venir a Venezuela
justamente acá ahí yo creo que una
prioridad en la agenda del presidente
Petro en la cual claramente está
buscando primero tratar de que Venezuela
se reinserte en la comunidad
internacional a través de la comunidad
andina de Naciones pero también a través
del sistema interamericano de Derechos
Humanos tema que yo creo que puede ser
fundamental para efectos de destrancar
parte de la crisis política en Venezuela
así como la gente económica y la agenda
comercial que claramente ha estado
frenada por la acción de grupos armados
no estatales pero también por años
de descontrol que ha habido en la
frontera como usted lo mencionaba Petro
pidió a maduro regresar al sistema
interamericano de Derechos Humanos cómo
será recibido este país en los
organismos regionales
Mira
esto pasa por un tema de la oea pasa por
el reconocimiento también como vimos
previamente en este la reunión de este
organismo en la asamblea general en la
que claramente están tratando de buscar
la fórmula en la que sea el
representante de maduro el que está allí
sentado y ya no el representante de
guaidó a pesar de que esto no tuvo los
votos necesarios en la última reunión
puede ser visto de una manera positiva
Siempre y cuando se respete el estado de
derecho y los dictámenes que puede haber
por parte de la Comisión Interamericana
o de la Corte Interamericana en una
cantidad de hechos que muchos
caracterizan como violaciones de
derechos humanos o como atentados en
contra de los derechos humanos y que
claramente pueden ayudar a Venezuela si
logra resarcir estos dictámenes o lo que
emanen de esta organismo jurisdiccional
claramente reinsertarlo o darle un
barniz de mayor legitimidad a su
gobierno
ahora con el regreso de Lula da Silva al
poder en Brasil se consolida tal vez el
fin del aislamiento a maduro
Mira yo creo que hay unas altas
probabilidades de que cuente con un
Aliado lo que hay que entender que
claramente hoy esta gran izquierda que
estamos viendo en toda latinoamérica No
necesariamente representa lo que
significó esa gran marea roja en la
época de Lula da Silva Hugo Chávez Evo
Morales y otros mandatarios que
claramente estuvieron inclinados a una
agenda completamente distinta y que
contó por detrás de ellos a una gran
petrochequera y a una cantidad
importante de ingreso en materia de
commodities entre otras entre otras
fuentes de ingresos importantes para la
región